And now it's the old scout master,
The old scouter.
He likes to come and visit the troop meetings once in a while.
He likes to keep up with what we're doing and you know, talk scouting.
He's getting on in years. so his wife has to help him get there.
She drives him over to the meeting house and helps him get inside
and she'll sit there with him and it's great.
He can talk to the scouts and share stories and things like that.
and he was there the other night and I said:
listen, do you remember? you told me about a backpacking trail
You used to take the scouts out on and it had a waterfall.
It was a beautiful place and I can't remember the name of the place.
Do you remember the name of the place?
He says, oh, of course. of course I remember the name.
And I said: well, can you tell me what it was?
He says, oh, yeah, yeah,
What's the name of the flower?
The red flower, right,
Did she get for Valentine's Day?
And stuff like that.
I said: do you mean Rose?
And he says that's right, that's right.
And he turns to his wife and he says: Rose,
what was the name of the trail with the waterfall where I used to
All. right, this is podcast number 193..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green
And we begin, as we always do, with the mailbag.
Dave Self got in touch with us through Facebook.
He said I listened to my first podcast, episode 192, tonight.
Great show,
I'm glad to have a quality scouting podcast to listen to.
Looking on iTunes, I don't see any of the older episodes.
Well, Dave, we're working on fixing that.
But in the meantime go to scoutmastercgcom
and you'll see in the main menu a link to the podcast archive.
That's where all the old shows are.
You can download them.
You can listen to them online,
Also on Facebook. Skip Tampke got in touch with us and said
I met two Eagle candidates the other night at a border review,
Two very different Scouts, both outstanding candidates.
Based on what I'm seeing at boards of review this year,
the future of America is in good hands,
Skip. I heartily agree
And thanks for getting in touch.
Mike Marty is in Reinhold, Pennsylvania,
and he's the scoutmaster of Troop 214.
And he wrote to say thanks for the great site.
I've been browsing your daily emails for some time
and just recently started listening to the podcast as I drive to work.
I'm a scoutmaster for a new troop.
My involvement with scouting started years ago
when I took my oldest son to a role in Tigers
And I also signed up to be the Tiger Dan leader.
Both of my sons are in Scouts, working on their Eagle.
Both have autism, but they're very high-functioning.
This has been a bit of a challenge.
Sometimes I inflict those challenges on myself
when I try to protect them too much.
Recently my youngest son completed national youth leader training
and the OA ordeal.
What made this possible was my not being involved
and the Scouts and the adults in leadership
at those events having an open mind.
The majority of Scouts in our troop
are identified with one learning difference or another.
We work to reach out to boys who really need Scouts.
Once again, thanks for helping me be a better scout leader.
Thanks, Mike.
Thanks for the kind words and thanks for getting in touch.
Eric Humann writes to us from actually the north of France
and says thanks for the work you do
and for sharing your knowledge.
Well, thank you, Eric.
Thanks for being in touch.
Here's a response from the anonymous writer of an email
we talked about in podcast 192..
Thanks for your personal email response to my question
and your response on the podcast,
The distinction between objective and subjective requirements
and the point that we are looking for individual progress
is very helpful.
I'll encourage my troop committee and our advancement chair
to take a listen to the podcast and see what happens.
Thanks for all you do.
In fact, I really don't know how you do it.
You must be retired or independently wealthy
or have a very understanding wife.
Well, I'm not retired
and I'm not independently wealthy by any means.
but you hit the nail on the head,
I do have a very understanding wife.
Thanks for getting in touch and thanks for your kind words.
As I've been talking about on the last few podcasts,
my new book, The Scouting Journey,
is on its own little journey to completion right now
And you know it takes more than just getting it all written.
It has to be proofed and all that stuff
And slowly but surely we're seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
And our publication date is mid-November.
It looks like we're going to be on track.
so more news about that later.
On November 10th, which is a Sunday
from 9 to 10 pm Eastern Daylight Time,
we'll be doing our next Scout Circle at scoutscircleorg
And that'll be about the transition from Weebelows to Scout.
Make sure to tune in and have a listen,
And in this podcast I have a story to tell you.
It's a good Halloween story,
And then we're going to answer some email questions.
That's going to constitute the remainder of this transmission.
So let's get started. shall we
Bride me a letter? send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Brian Rodini asked this question.
We have several parents that do participate regularly
with the troop on camping events
and direct scouts in what feels like everything.
They're cooking duties, cleaning up, later
getting ready for a hike.
Their intentions are good, but they interfere a lot.
They tell scouts to move over and let them show you
how to do something, or that they'll take care
of putting the tents away.
Over the course of several years
I've spoken to a parent or two and the scout master has.
The committee chair has asked them please to step back
and enjoy the camp out and let the boys do what patrols do,
But it's not working very well.
So as the assistant scout master,
who is soon to become scout master,
I am able to interact and work with my scouts.
Trying to get the message to parents to stop interfering
with the scouts is another matter.
Brian, thanks for getting in touch.
I'll tell you that there's absolutely no question
that parents who are not registered volunteers
don't really belong on camping trips or in troop meetings.
Somehow things have gone astray here
and you're going to need to make that stop.
It's a simple fix really.
Tell parents, if they want to participate on a regular basis,
that they need to register as scout leaders
and complete their training.
Otherwise they're just not going to be welcome
on camping trips or at meetings,
unless they'd like to observe a meeting or a camping trip.
You know that's fine,
But there are rules.
Observers watch and they don't participate.
They don't coach or interfere
and they're going to need to learn to control themselves.
You can't talk parents out of interfering
because they don't see it as interfering.
You can train scouters to do things properly.
Now I'm not sure where everyone got the idea
that scout camping is some kind of family event.
It's not.
None of the parents who are interfering
with a scout camping trip would do something
like suit up and head out on the field
to play in their child's soccer game.
If they did, the referee would throw them off the field.
Remember this:
The scout master coaches and advises scouts
and they lead adults.
If adults won't follow the leader.
they really just can't be part of what's going on.
Get together with your committee chair
and come up with a strategy you can agree on
to address this,
And you're going to have to tell parents
in no uncertain terms that these things
are going to change.
I'll tell you what my general kind of standing order
is for adults.
One adult- the scout master, when he's present
and his designee when he's not,
interacts with and directs youth leadership
and scouts during meetings and camping trips.
No one else speaks to or directs
any youth leader or scout
without going through the scout master.
When scouts are meeting or camping,
that's game time.
No parents are allowed on the field.
No adult volunteers are allowed on the field.
They can observe and they can offer help,
but they're going to do that
by talking to the scout master.
When we go camping, there's an area for adults
at a good remove from the scouts,
within sight, but as many yards away as possible.
Adults do not go into the scouts area
unless they have my permission,
and no scout other than the senior patrol leader
enters the adult area.
This would be a very big change
from what you described.
It's going to take a little while to make it work
and it could cause a little bit of difficulty,
but you'll be equal to the challenge
if you gather together the resources
in the scout master handbook
and in the scout handbook and from your training
that delineate the role of parents
and the role of volunteers
and the role of youth leader.
I received this and it was requested
that I withhold the name of the person who sent it to me.
They wrote in to say this:
first of all, I love the podcast in the site.
I began listening six months ago
and I've now started from the beginning
and I'm working my way through the podcast archives.
The insight you share with your audience
is extremely useful
and it's fun to listen to.
I've enjoyed reading your recommendations
and read as much as I can find out about scouting,
its history and its methods.
I appreciate the kind words.
Here's my dilemma.
I'm an assistant scout master
with a group of about 60 scouts.
I came up through scouting
as a den leader, unit commissioner
and the father of a scout.
I've noticed in the six months
I've been involved with the troop
that there are some challenges
and a few red flags with the program.
Most all of the problems
stem from adults taking command
when they believe the meeting or event
is becoming chaotic
and they have a general feeling
that the boys can't lead
and they really care about the scouts
and want them to have the best experience possible,
but they seem to feel it requires
stepping in too much of the time.
The current scout master is retiring
and the committee is looking for a replacement.
I was asked to take the position
and under the circumstances
I would gladly jump into this volcano,
But for the next 18 months
I'm going to miss
about half of the troop meetings
because of a work commitment.
The committee discussed the conflict that I had
and they decided that, while it may be difficult,
they still wanted me to be scout master
and that other adults
could fill in when I am absent.
I appreciate their support
and their desire to compromise,
but I see this kind of scout master by committee
to be a disaster in the making.
I'm pretty sure I'd be able to coax the youth
and adults along towards the youth-led
patrol method style of troop
if I could be there full time,
but under this scenario
I'm not sure it'll work.
I need your advice.
Have you seen this type of setup work before,
where a scout master is only at a portion of meetings
and other adults are filling in when he can't attend.
I know I can be a good scout master,
but I don't think I should take the job on
if I can't do it well.
Well, that's a very interesting situation
that you describe,
and it's always a tough decision.
but I gotta say you're asking the right question.
To my mind, the whole thing boils down to one thought,
and it's the same one that I shared
in answer to the last email:
that scout master leads adults.
He coaches and serves as an advisor
to the scouts, but he leads adults.
When he tells adults what to do,
they fall in line.
Now, the situation you describe could work,
but there are some
important caveats.
Be very clear about your vision
and precisely how you
expect adults to behave
once you become the scout master.
Here's what I would advise you to: tell
the troop committee
that you, as the scout master,
are the only adult who
attends the patrol leaders council meetings.
You reserve the right to invite others,
but no one else attends without your invitation.
You will bring the plans
that the patrol leaders council
has developed to the committee.
The committee functions to support
the patrol leaders council through the scout master,
not to pass judgment on
the plans of the patrol leaders council-
No votes, no picking things apart.
They find the way
to make the patrol leaders council's
plans happen.
Only one adult- and that will be you
as the scout master when you're there,
or the person you designate,
and that just needs to be one person-
interacts with
and directs the youth leadership during
meetings and camping trips.
No one else
speaks to or directs
any youth leader.
If you're going to do this, choose
one person who will fill in for you.
you can't be there, Not a team,
not three or four different people.
one person, and I'm not suggesting
that that person is called
a scout master or that you're co-scout
masters. There's only one scout master
and they call the shots,
and the other person is an assistant
scout master. They do
as you direct. Now, the adults involved
are no doubt wonderful, helpful
people who are doing what they think is
best, and they're going to be a little
or a lot worried about these things
and they're probably going to tell you that they just won't
work. Tell them that they will
work. It won't be nice and neat,
but it will work if you give
it enough time. I would estimate it's going to
take a year or two
of concentrated effort on your part
to turn things around. Some things
happen quickly, others take
much longer than any of us can imagine.
I would come up with a plan, I would
put it in writing. I would give it to the
committee. If they want to modify
or vote on or bargain over the points
in that plan, I'd probably
end up passing on the opportunity
of serving as a scout master. I'll
repeat again: The scout master
coaches and guides scouts,
but he leads adults.
If the adults won't follow your lead,
they'll need to find somebody else to be the scout
master. Howie Jones
from Troop 570
in Springfield, Massachusetts, asks
a dad's interested in being
an assistant scout master. He asked:
what are you looking for in an
assistant? And that leads me to ask you:
what do you think the relationship between
the scout master and assistant scout masters
ought to be? How do I build a good
working and training relationship
with assistant scout masters? Well,
Howie, my advice comes from a specific
context and that's a troop
applying the patrol method.
When the patrol method is in action,
scouts are leading, of course, and in a
lot of ways there's not that much for adults
to do. We do invite every parent
to participate in some supporting
role and we welcome those who respond.
I've watched the overall
ratio of assistant scout masters
to scouts climb
really steadily in other troops
over the past few years. I have
to question the need for more than three
adults attending a camping trip.
I've seen troops where the ratio
is close to one adult
for every scout.
Now what do those adults do? How
can youth leaders have a fighting chance
if there are that many adults around?
More to the point, my working relationship
with assistant scout masters
is principally defined by their availability.
Most of my assistant scout masters
are busy people with families
and we tell every adult volunteer
that they set their level of involvement.
No one's ever going to give them a hard
time about it. If they can't be
there, they can't be there. We've never
really had a problem getting adults
for camping trips and I think part
of the reason is we let them set their
own expectations and level
of involvement. When somebody
does step up and join us as an
assistant scout master, the first
thing I tell them is: I
am their leader, They follow me
and they do what I say. I am
completely unambiguous about this
and for the third time in this
podcast I repeat: I
advise scouts
and I lead adults.
My first responsibility
as a leader of adults is to make
sure that they do not
interfere with the game. Since our
boundary lines aren't painted on the floor
or chalked on a field, I have
to shell assistant scout masters
where those lines are. I tell
them. if they doubt where they should be
or what they should be doing,
they should stand next to me. then
they know they're in the right place.
New assistant scout masters are encouraged
to get trained beyond the
required youth protection training.
I encourage them to take every online
course that they can. Over the past
years, our district and council training
events have grown smaller and smaller
and there are fewer opportunities for
in-person training. I try
to get assistant scout masters to listen
in when I'm training youth leaders
and this seems to help a great deal.
and as I have run
all of the training required to be
an assistant scout master many
times over the years, I usually
go through these sessions with my
assistants piecemeal over
a few months if they can't get
to one of the regular training sessions.
I have found that a new assistant scout master
without any scouting background gets on
board a lot faster than a former cub leader
or most eagle scouts.
People with scouting experience have some
preconceptions that may or may not
jive with the patrol system,
and we butt heads from time to time,
but with a sense of perspective,
some good humor and some
unambiguous direction, we
usually solve those problems pretty fast
How. I hope that helps.
I'd love to get your email question too,
and I'll tell you how to get in touch
in just a moment.
This has to be the truth, folks,
because there is no
way
anyone could make this up.
John was one of my fellow scout masters
here in our district. We struck up a friendship
years ago when we were working together
in a scout master training course.
One thing led to another
and we ended up
co-sponsoring
a district camperee.
We got the boys from both troops together
to plan the camperee and present things,
and we wanted to have
some kind of special feature
at the Saturday night campfire.
so John and I started putting our heads together
about that and since
the camperee was scheduled later
in October, right around the time of Halloween,
we decided that
we would go ahead and get
pumpkins so that when
the troops arrived at the camperee
we would present them with a pumpkin
with the instructions to make it into
a jack-o'-lantern
and they would bring that jack-o'-lantern
to the Saturday night campfire
and we'd put the jack-o'-lanterns out at the campfire
and it would
create a kind of cool Halloween
atmosphere there
around the campfire.
The program for the campfire was pretty simple.
I got to be the emcee,
I was asked to have their patrols come up
with skits and songs and things like that,
and we lined them up and we got things ready
and I don't know
exactly how
we struck on the idea
of the pumpkin man.
I don't know if it was John's idea
or if it was my idea,
but somehow
we ended up
deciding that we should have
a pumpkin man
visit the Saturday night campfire.
so what do I mean by a pumpkin man?
well, you'd have to meet John to understand this
and I don't think he'd be upset
if I told you that John's
build is kind of
pumpkin-like.
he was a solid guy
and if you had to
pick out somebody
to be a pumpkin man out of a lineup-
and John was in that lineup-
you'd probably pick John.
now somehow-
I don't know how-
he came across
a fluorescent
orange jumpsuit
with all kinds of
white reflective
panels on it and things.
it looked like a cross between an airline pilot
and one of the guys
that works out along the highway.
we got down to the campery,
we distributed the pumpkins
and we went through all of the Saturday
activities and Saturday night
rolled around and it was time
for the big campery campfire.
and this campfire was held
in this kind of wonderful natural
amphitheater we have at one of our
scout camps. there's a creek in the
background
and kind of the stage
is just right there
high on the bank of the creek
and then up the hill
near the creek there are benches
in this kind of nice natural
amphitheater.
John got into his pumpkin
man outfit
that day- glow orange jumpsuit-
and he got himself out of sight
down towards the creeks
and nobody could see him.
and you know, at the right
time the scout started to filter into
the campfire circle
and of course they brought their pumpkins.
and as the pumpkins came in we took
them and we sat them
around the campfire in a big
semi circle. it looked great
and we started the campfire
with a song and then it was time
for the first skit and what we
had done is we had this
log, this kind of a stump,
and we set that over
to one side of the campfire
and the idea was,
when your troop came
down to do a skit, we would take
your pumpkin right
and we would set it on the log
and we would say, hey, here's troop
15's pumpkin,
and what do you think of this pumpkin,
isn't it gorgeous? and everybody would go
yay, and then we would put it on the log
and they would come out and do their skit.
so the first troop came up,
we put the pumpkin on the log
and they came out and did their skit.
and of course you know I came out afterwards
and it was
naturally. it was one of those skits
that you've seen, you know, several hundred
times, right?
if you've been to more than one scout
campfire, you know exactly what I'm talking about.
there's seems to be,
by regulation, almost
a number of skits that must be part
of each and every campfire.
so this skit- you know it was
fine, they did a fine job
of it- is one that a lot of people had seen before,
and so after the skit
was over and the applause died down
a little bit, I stepped out and I said, well,
let's give a cheer
for that skit.
and I forget exactly what cheer we gave,
did a cheer and everything,
and I asked the audience.
I said, well, what did you really think of that skit?
and you know how scouts are
they're.
they told us their opinion and it was mixed.
and I said: you know,
I have a friend here
who also might have an opinion about this skit.
I said because it's close to Halloween,
we have all these jack-o'-lanterns here.
I invited my friend the pumpkin man
to come and be with us this evening
and I looked off
and I said: hello, pumpkin man.
pumpkin man, are you there?
and John kind of popped up
from behind the creek bank
in this crazy orange jumpsuit
and strode up to the campfire
nonchalantly and we shook hands
and I welcomed him to the campfire,
introduced him to the scouts and I said: so,
pumpkin man, did you,
did you see the last skit?
and he said, yeah, I saw the last skit.
and I said: wasn't it great?
didn't you think that was a great skit?
not really.
and I said: well, pumpkin man, please,
we're trying to be kind here-
are you sure you
didn't like the last skit?
he said, no, not really
seen that skit a lot of times.
I don't think they did very well.
and of course this was all coming off the cuff.
it was a joke and everybody understood
in the way that we were doing it,
so no feelings were hurt,
but I got to
honestly disagree with you, pumpkin man.
it was a great skit. and he said:
you want to know what I really thought of that skit.
and I said, yeah, that's why I brought you out,
I want you to give us your opinion.
he walked out of the campfire light
and he came back with-
have you guessed it yet?
good old John had spent part of the afternoon
gathering the materials
and putting together
a giant mallet.
I mean, this thing was huge.
it was probably about four or five feet long.
it had a big log
12 inches in diameter as the mallet head
on it and he brought that out
and there was a little murmur
that started to go through the crowd
once he got a big hammer for it.
what's this all about?
and John looked at
the jack-o'-lantern
that was sitting on the log,
the troop who had just done
their skit- and he said:
so you really want me to tell you what I thought of that skit?
and once again I said
yeah, I really want you to tell you
that skit. he says that pumpkin there
that belongs to the guys who did the skit.
and I said yeah,
and the murmur in the crowd
started to go up a little bit now
and they started to get a little excited
because they saw the pumpkin
sitting there on the log.
they saw the pumpkin men
and they saw the giant mallet
and in their fevered imagination
they started to make
some connections.
the pumpkin man took a couple of strides over to the log
and he lifted up that mallet
and he brought it down with a resounding
crash
and smashed the pumpkin into a thousand pieces
pieces
and a roar
of approbation went up from the crowd
like none you've ever heard in a scout camp before.
they were thrilled.
the guys who made the jack-o'-lantern were thrilled.
the rest of the scouts were thrilled.
they thought it was the best thing they had ever seen.
and so the pumpkin man
took a bow and went off
stage again and it was time for
the next troop to come up and do their skit.
and dutifully,
as they took the stage,
I inquired as to which jack-o'-lantern was theirs
and I put that on the stump
where they now smashed jack-o'-lantern
used to sit
and they went ahead and they did their skit.
and at the end of the skit
I said: well, what did you guys think of that skit?
you know how
scouts are. they were calling
and carrying on
and I said: shall we ask the pumpkin man
what he thought of the skit?
yes, ask the pumpkin man.
so John strides back out
and I said, pumpkin man, what did you really think of that skit?
he says, well, it wasn't too bad.
it was a little bit better than the last one.
and I still don't like it very much.
and I said now, pumpkin man, come on,
they were doing their best.
they came out and they gave us a great skit,
don't you think that? nah,
I really didn't like that skit.
and he looks at the crowd and he says,
yes, yes, we want to know.
and so he strides over to the stump
where the poor innocent jack-o'-lantern
is sitting
and he lifts his mallet up over his head
and he brings it down and he stops
and he puts the mallet down
and he rubs his hands together,
he spits into his palms
and he picks the mallet up again,
brings it up over his head,
he brings it crashing down on that pumpkin
and it goes, blow into smithereens
all over the place.
the crowd goes wild again
and it was time then
to bring the third troop up for their skit.
and we found their pumpkin
and we put it on the stump
where the poor innocent pumpkins
that had been smashed to the thus far head-sat
and this troop went ahead
and got into a skit
and they got a couple minutes in
and pretty soon the crowd was chanting:
pumpkin man,
and you know,
it was almost impossible to stop them.
it was a runaway train
and of course, out comes the pumpkin man,
down comes the hammer
and another jack-o'-lantern smashed.
well, we had
a fantastic time that evening.
it was one of the best campfires
I've ever been to,
oft commented on, and everybody
had a blast and we smashed
15 or 20 pumpkins
and everybody thought it was just
wonderful.
now that would be enough of a story to tell,
but let me dial ahead a year or so.
John and I
end up down at camp for one reason or another-
I really can't remember why,
and I'm talking to him and we're just
kind of catching up- and he said
that thing at the camperee that went over great.
and I said, yeah, the pumpkin man.
I said that was fantastic.
he said yep, yep.
last month the pumpkin man came
to visit the Cub Scout camp
and I said, John,
you didn't, did you?
he said yeah, it didn't turn out
to be a very good idea, though.
I said, John what happened?
he said: well, we did the same thing.
we told all the dens to make a jack-o'-lantern
and bring it with them to the campfire,
and we did the same thing.
their mothers got kind of angry
with us, though, because they spent
an awful long time working on those jack-o'-lanterns,
and so from that
day forward, at least as far
as Cubs were concerned, the pumpkin man
went into retirement.
thanks for listening to this
193rd edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast.
all of the past editions of the podcast
are available for download or listening
on our podcast archive
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
while you're there, you can join
over 2,500 email subscribers
and receive updates to the blog
by email.
you can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
or access the podcast on a mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
get details about how to make that happen
at Stitchercom.
you can stay in touch with us
and help spread the word through the
vast panorama of social media
outlets.
join over 4,200 folks who follow us
at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
join our 800 plus Twitter
followers at ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
subscribe to watch us
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
and join the hundreds who have been admitted
to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle
by looking for
ScoutmasterCG on Google plus,
if you find social media a little scary
and confusing, well, that's alright,
you can zoom into the late 90's
and email me.
that's right. the email address is
clark. at ScoutmasterCGcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping. Why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.